الى مصر حيث اعرب الرئيس عبد الفتاح
السيسي عن رفض الربطه بين الازمه
الاقتصاديه التي تمر بها البلاد والاتفاق
على المشروعات الكبرى والبنيه التحتيه
وقال في كلمه خلال احتفال اقيم بمناسبه
عيد الشرطه ان العالم يمر بازمه اقتصاديه
هي الاكبر منذ الكساد الكبير بدايه القرن
الماضيه واشعر الى ان تاثير الازمه على
بلاده كان كبيرا نظرا لاندماج الاقتصاد
المصري في الاقتصاد العالمي بشكل كبير على
حديقه
توجد اسئله
كاشفه يجب طرحها
علينا جميعا
هل توجد ازمه اقتصاديه عنيفه وغير مسبوقه
في العالم ام لا
وهل تعاني اكبر اقتصادات العالم واكثرها
تقدما على نحو لم نشهده منذ عقود طويله
ربما منذ ازمنه الكساد الكبير والحربين
العالمين
الم ينتج عن تلك التداعيات بيعرف دوليه
الان بالازمه العالميه لغلاء المعيشه
اليس من المنطقي والطبيعي بل هو المحتوم
ان تنعكس هذه الازمه علينا في مصر وتكون
لها تداعيات سلبيه كبيره ونحن جزء من
الاقتصاد العالمي
بقوه خلال العقود الاخيره